the Heisenberg uncertainty principle has
to be one of the coolest and also one of
the most misunderstood and abused ideas
in physics so before I explain it to you
I want you to pick which of these three
statements you think is the uncertainty
principle now this isn't to embarrass
you it's because it really helps to know
where your preconceived understanding is
flawed to be able to fix it so please
please do it it's for your own good and
even if you don't know the principal or
none of these seem perfect just pick the
one that sounds most right to you and in
the corner of the video you can find a
poll where you can enter your guess
please pause the video now to read all
of these and decide all right
I hope you've made your choice maybe
you'll be surprised but both one and two
are very wrong they demonstrate quite
fundamental misconceptions about quantum
mechanics but what's worse they make the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle sound
like it's about measuring here's the
thing it's not about measurement the
principle works whether or not you ever
measure the particle but before I
explain that let me try and convince you
that the other two options really are
just not right
option one first the really big issue
with this option is that it says quantum
particles really have a position and a
momentum just like classical physics but
they're just shy about it this is not at
all what quantum mechanics says what
quantum mechanics says is a particle
doesn't have just one place or one speed
it's going out instead while they're not
observed they can be in what we call a
superposition of many places and many
speeds but say you do go to measure it
you can only measure one thing about the
particle so let's say you're measuring
the position you're not going to see it
in all of these places it will just be
in one and it will pick which one
randomly and so that's one reason the
first answer is wrong when you measure a
particle it doesn't tell you some range
of places or any other information about
where it is it just turns up in one
single place and what's worse is you
can't measure it again and hope to see
all these other spot
now it's not in a superposition of
different positions anymore if you
measure it again it will certainly be in
this place in the language of quantum
mechanics a measurement collapses the
state so the particle is no longer doing
what it was before so it's pretty
meaningless now to measure the speed and
try and deduce anything about the
particle speed before you measured
anything no you've ruined the original
state I mean you can measure the speed
just like with the position and it will
tell you just one speed but that is in
no way the speed the particle was really
going at or even related to the
superposition of speeds the particle was
in originally so in summary the particle
didn't have just one speed or position
but let's say you measure it say its
position it would only tell you one of
the places and which one is random plus
you can't ask it again to get more
information because it's no longer in a
superposition of places and worse you
can't ask the particle about its
momentum now the value you get is
completely unrelated to the original
super positions of momentum on the other
hand this option says that the particle
really has one speed and one position
and that you can get some range of
information about the particles position
and that you can then go and ask about
the momentum as well what about the
second option this has got to be one of
the most popular explanations of the
uncertainty principle and it's just so
confusing because it's completely
unrelated to the uncertainty principle
the principle is not about some very
specific setup for measuring position
implying that it is leads people to ask
the very sensible question well why
don't I just come up with a better way
to do it the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle is not about measurement at
all I'll explain in a sec but first
let's address the issues of this one it
has some pretty similar misconceptions
that the particle really has one
position and one momentum and we're
trying to outwit it to find them both
out it also seems to say that the
uncertainty is from knocking the
particle or in some other way
just
having the particle bio measurement like
I said before the uncertainty has
nothing to do with measurement it's
actually about the range of different
speeds in the superposition this range
is the uncertainty referred to by the
principle but uncertainty is a sort of
unfortunate term for it uncertainty
makes people think that there is a speed
but we're uncertain about what it is but
no quantum mechanics is so much weirder
and more exciting than that I mean this
second option is basically classical
there's pretty much nothing there that
you wouldn't expect from real life
quantum mechanics is not what you'd
expect from real life so let me explain
the real Heisenberg uncertainty
principle as I was saying before the
particle is in a superposition of many
places but it's not usually equally in
all of those places some places are
weighted more heavily which means that
if you were to measure it it's more
likely to turn up in one of those places
but we're not going to measure it okay
there's no measurement if this entire
thing just to make that clear now let's
say a particle is most likely to turn up
in certain areas there's a way to
mathematically describe the total size
of these likely areas will use the
symbol Delta X so a particle could have
a really small Delta X which means that
it's mostly in a superposition over a
very small area which again means that
if we were to measure where it is then
we could make a pretty good guess about
where the particle will turn up this is
probably why the term uncertainty is
used to describe Delta X because it
means how much we're uncertain about
what result we would have if we were to
measure it I just don't like that word
because of the connotation that the
particle really is in one place but we
didn't have enough knowledge to know
where no even with all the knowledge
that quantum mechanics says is possible
for anyone there is still this
randomness when you measure okay so we
can similarly talk about momentum the
particle is in a superposition of speeds
so which speeds are weighted the most
heavily again you'll find it's some
range and you quantify the size of this
range math
matically in exactly the same way and
call it delta p now we have the stage
set for understanding that famous
misused equation what it says is in
quantum mechanics Delta X and Delta P
can't both be as small as you want
see if Delta X was really really really
really small but so is Delta P their
product would be very small and that's
no good it has to be bigger than this
number this is significant because while
it's true that in quantum mechanics we
know that the particle is in a
superposition we might have wanted to
minimize how bad this is we might have
thought well at least if the particle
won't just go at one speed we could come
up with a way to really really narrow
down the range of speeds in the
superposition and then even if we had to
accept that the particle is in a
superposition of many places at least we
can make it mostly in one small area
then this particle has almost one speed
and almost one position at a time and
that means it's almost a classical
particle so it had act almost the way
we'd like it to but the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle destroys that
possibility there is no way to make a
particle almost classical in position
and almost classical in momentum one or
both have to give the world is quantum
not classical no matter what we wish if
you're new here and you've made it to
this point I'm honestly impressed I'm
pretty sure that plenty of these points
seemed really odd or were poorly
explained but if you're interested in
knowing the details of quantum mechanics
then you can start here for everyone
else I hope this video was a little bit
of a break after the last one I am
working on a video that's a little bit
more technical and will go into the
derivation of the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle but that one may not be up for
a little while anyway just one very
quick homework question for this video
what happens if you measure the position
of a particle and then the momentum and
then the position again is it going to
be in the same spot or not all right see
you next time